right now we're being dictated
stylistically by like you know the john
wick films and like the raid movies i
think that's kind of where like at least
where i'm like that's what i think of
when i think of like this generation's
action stuff
james tell us about your decision as a
director and a producer to move from
horror into action films so i i really
started like deciding i wanted to do
action movies uh because i just started
noticing like there's not really like a
lot of like super low budget action
movies and i'd hit this wall in horror
where like you know
i kind of had to like reinvent myself
because oh i was making like you know
150 200 000 300 000 horror movies and
what would happen is you know producers
would be like oh how much did you make
this for and i'd tell them and they'd be
like wow like i used to think people
would be like oh
he made it for two hundred thousand
dollars imagine what he could do with
three million but they'd be like oh he
made it for two hundred thousand dollars
this guy's good at two hundred thousand
dollars let's give him two hundred
thousand dollars
so i was like oh crap i need to like you
know
go up higher and i wanted to work with
more name talent like more recognizable
name talent and so i was like okay well
action my friend was making action at
the time and he was getting like big
names and so i was like okay that's the
way to do it go into action and so i
went over towards action and immediately
like budgets go up and you're able to
get more name talent because
you're making an action movie and i
guess they know that you have to have a
certain amount of things to do an action
movie uh so the budgets are are
higher typically
you know horror you can make much more
contained in a house and that's not to
say there aren't more contained action
but typically you know you're going to
be able to attract bigger talent and and
more money
so with or you know how you have to have
a scare within a certain amount of time
and then scares in between or kills yeah
pretty much have to have something going
on every 10 minutes in a horror movie
okay to engage the audience and you want
to open up with like a stinger of like
some scary thing happening in the first
like few minutes
well with action what are those sort of
you know
tried and true rules that you have to
have like so an explosion so as as crazy
as it sounds you got to have some type
of action moment in the first like five
minutes of the movie and then you've got
to have stuff every 10 minutes so it's
it's
it's almost literally the exact same uh
same same thing you're just swapping out
you know action for horror um it's i
would assume it's the same for comedy
you got to have something really funny
happen in the beginning and then you
have jokes every like you know every you
know a good amount of like set-piece
jokes happening every you know 10
minutes i think that's you know
more so not about the genre but about
like you know audiences in general need
uh that type of um structure and that
type of uh
content coming in you need to have uh
you'll lose the attention of the
audience if you don't have
certain set pieces happening every 10
minutes
a lot of the slow burn stuff that people
like i know a lot of you know times when
i'm talking with other filmmakers
they're like oh i love you know the
movies like the witch and this and that
and i love those movies too but those
are like the exception not the rule if
that makes sense those are the ones that
like went to sundance and and got like a
big following and did well um you know
typically audiences want stuff that hits
the certain beats so that they it keeps
their attention uh especially when we're
in this avod world now with stuff like
tubey where your filmmakers are getting
paid by how long somebody watches the
movie not by if they rent it
so you want stuff happening that keeps
their attention and keeps them watching
the full amount of the movie
have you ever sort of broken down the
psychology of the horror um audience
member the horror enthusiast versus the
action film enthusiast like who are
those people can they ever cross over no
i haven't but i feel like it kind of has
some crossover for sure because i mean
like a lot of the a lot of the action
movies i loved uh you know from the the
80s and 90s you know had a lot of
similarities to the horror movies i
loved they had like non-stop you know
blood and gore and craziness i mean you
look at like any of like the paul
verhoeven films like you know you look
at like robocop i mean that's kind of
like an action and a horror movie in its
own right um you look at stuff like
demolition man like that has like this
sci-fi element so there's a lot of
crossover i think uh and i do think that
genre fans in general uh have some some
crossover though i do feel like horror
audiences are more used to watching um
horror movies that don't necessarily
have name talent it's more about the
situation and the and the special
effects whereas like action audiences
like seeing like the person that they
like seeing kick ass kick ass
right and you said that you love the 90s
even though you're a child of the 90s
but there's something
very you you're very drawn to it i feel
like a lot of people could tell because
my casts i usually cast people from the
90s like i go after like 90s names i go
after people that like were super cool
when i was like watching tv and i'm like
oh that's cool like or like when i was
watching like movies like i go after the
stuff that i grew up on i think like you
know 80s and 90s is like really like
where i'm i'm really most keyed in
as uh as as a filmmaker
and so what little telltale signs
could we see from your films that have
an 80s 90s influence aside from the
names that a current day film would be
different like what are you using a
perfect example is like you know survive
the game the the uh the first bruce
willis movie i directed um i i really
wanted to make that kind of feel like
the old school joel silver action movies
it didn't take itself too seriously it's
non-stop action there's a lot of jokes
it's it's supposed to be funny and it
was like you know i almost like went
like okay almost like the last action
hero chad michael murray's character
falls asleep and then when he wakes up
uh it's almost as if he's waking up in
his own action movie so like everything
is larger than life full of cliches and
like you know i'm kind of playing
towards that like 90s sensibility and
then on top of that i'm using like a lot
of like 90s like uh
famous songs like well not songs but
artists so i had like some dmx music in
there who i was you know i was friends
with dmx before he passed away we did a
couple projects together and
um you know i just kind of
thought um you know that that's it's
just i i play towards that and i also
think like some of the
the style to the film as well like you
know you opening the film up more bigger
wides uh kind of how i like to shoot the
action as well it kind of plays towards
the stylistic sense of the 90s versus a
lot of stuff is more fast paced and
quicker now and i do kind of merge it
now with like this quicker cutting thing
like i kind of do the frenetic camera
work and i'll do like you know shooting
at like a 45 degree shutter and then 22
frames a second at the same time for an
action sequence so it can kind of speed
it up and then i'll yank out frames and
kind of do that sort of stuff for the
fight scenes but i kind of do that
in the scope of also kind of keeping
like 90s colors and framing if that
makes sense and i think that's kind of a
little bit more fun
right i think i remember with the first
born movie
which i really enjoyed that one was a
tiny bit slower than some of the others
that were just like too fast for me yeah
it was too frenetic yeah you didn't
breathe enough yeah well like you look
at like a movie like um
uh
a perfect example of some of like the
really close-up fighting scenes that
like became very popular uh and and were
very frenetic and very you know
fast-paced was uh batman begins like
that casey style of fighting that's like
in in batman begins where we're super
close up and everything's like handheld
like this i think that kind of you're
kind of like wait what's going on in
that and but that became like uh more of
a style of what we saw in like the late
2000s and i think you know if you if you
go back you know
uh
a lot of the action was kind of inspired
by like the further back you go was
inspired by a lot of the stuff that was
coming out of like asia so i think and
that was like much more seen in the why
because you wanted to see the person
actually doing this stuff if that makes
sense um you know so that's how like
people like you know li uh bruce lee and
jackie chan got famous is because they
could actually do the things and you
would see them do it
um
and then you know it's it's also
interesting because you look at stuff
like the matrix you know that that was
all about slowing stuff down and i think
uh
as as stuff goes on we like to we've
we've gone to speed it up so i've i've
kind of found like this hybrid style of
of between that and
what we're doing now
sure and if we think back to let's say
like miami vice or the show hunter i
don't know if you remember hunter i
don't but i remember miami vice oh okay
it's a great la based uh like cop show
and uh you know it had sort of this like
sort of sexy feel a little bit you know
with the with the you know han zimmer
sort of like feel of the music in the
background and uh you know i feel like
that a lot of that's lost it's it's not
you know i know with drive there was
some of that yeah yeah drive but drive
isn't quite an action movie it's more of
a
yeah it's more of like a thriller
um action
i think like what's kind of dictated
what happens is you get like a big
action movie that kind of dictates like
the style of action uh and like you know
right now we're being dictated
stylistically by like you know the john
wick films and like the raid movies i
think that's kind of where like at least
where i'm like that's what i think of
when i think of like this generation's
action stuff
um you know and i but like i think i
like playing a lot with like frame rate
and shutter speed so like i'll do stuff
either a 135 degree shutter or 90 degree
shutter or 45 degree shutter uh to kind
of enhance some of the moments and then
i really like doing like 22 frames a
second because it kind of makes it a
little bit more
frenetic
but i can kind of toy with it as well
and then slowing it down later for
certain beats
uh and then there's a lot of like you
know i'll do stuff in reverse
because it kind of sells the impact a
little bit more
um
but it's it's interesting because that
all comes from a horror background i
think as well because like you know when
i was playing with shutter speeds in the
in the past it would be when i was like
having a ghost move really weird and
then i would pull out frames and and
play with the shutter speed to like have
that happen and now i'm doing that in
action sequences to make it seem like
people are fighting like like much more
quick
um so i think it's it's it's interesting
as well as like some of the reverse
stuff you we'd do that in like a horror
movie you'd have an axe in the person's
head and you have them pull it out but
then you
you'd play that in reverse and it looked
like they slammed it right into the
person's head
um you know and then you just like you
use a v effect to reveal the wound um so
i think it's just it's kind of it's kind
of interesting
a lot of it is is
is similar in style like you could take
some sensibilities um and also sometimes
maybe people see some horror
sensibilities in the action movies that
i'm i'm making because you know i do
like like building tension before a
fight in a lot of it and a lot of that
is playing towards some of the
sensibilities i learned from like a
horror movie but instead of like a ghost
popping out at the end like a person
pops out and they get into a fist fight
so it sounds like the transition wasn't
that difficult then you you welcomed the
challenge yeah yeah i mean i think
stylistically for sure i welcomed the
challenge and it wasn't that difficult
uh in that sense um you know it's still
like a learning curve like i i was like
playing with different styles and i was
very lucky to work with like talented
editor talented dp on the action movies
i've been doing and stuff and as well as
like you know
very closely with my my stunt crews